the dawn of time was a critical moment
in the birth of the universe because
pure energy also produced one of the
most dangerous things in the universe
antimatter that's right
antimatter it's real
antimatter is the mirror image of
ordinary matter
however matter has one charge an
antimatter has the opposite charge if it
was an anti nini made out of antimatter
that person in principle could look
exactly like me same personality quirk
same everything
except of course when I decide to shake
his hand at that point we both would
blow ourselves to smithereens in a
gigantic nuclear explosions matter with
a positive charge locks horns with its
arch enemy antimatter with a negative
charge the fate of the universe hangs in
the balance of this epic battle equal
amounts of matter and antimatter will
cancel each other out not good the
universe with equal amounts of matter
and antimatter is equivalent to a
universe with no matter at all because
the matter and antimatter will
annihilate back into pure radiation and
there'll be nothing interesting no stars
and galaxies and people in between
like a cosmic game of risk the side with
the most soldiers wins the score was
very close but there was a winner for
every billion particles of antimatter
there were a billion in one particles of
matter that was the moment of creation
the one extra particle of matter in each
little volume survives survives enough
to form all the matter we see in the
stars and galaxies today